عليك أن تقول أن الاحتمالات هي أن بوتين
سيعزز السلطة من حوله، وأنه
سيكون قادرًا على فرض
سيطرة كاملة. تذكر أن بريغوسيان كان لديه 25000
شخص، الحرس الرئاسي الشخصي لبوتين
لديه مائتي ألف،
الجيش الروسي لديه مئات ومئات
الآلاف من الأشخاص في جميع أنحاء العالم.
جميع الحكام الإقليميين يدعمون بوتين، جميع الشخصيات الرئيسية في روسيا، كما
تعلمون، لا يوجد
شعور هنا بوجود دوامة تنازلية تخرج عن نطاق
السيطرة، ما رأيناه كان ثغرة في الدرع
ومن المهم أن تعرف أن
هذا هو ثغرة في الدرع الذي
بدا  مضاد للرصاص تمامًا ولكن دعونا
لا نبالغ، لم يكن الأمر في هذه
المرحلة لا يبدو أكثر من مجرد ثغرة لا
تعرفها أبدًا على الرغم من الشيء الذي نعرفه أنا
وأنت، بعد أن شاهدنا هذا
النوع من الأنظمة، أه الديكتاتوريات مثل
بوتين، تتمتع بهذه الجودة وهي  عندما
يكونون في مكانهم وفي السلطة يبدون
أبديين وعندما ينهارون يبدو الأمر
لا مفر منه